m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace 4 años salí de prisión
ustedes imaginan lo que significa pasar
11 años de tu vida en la cárcel cuál fue
mi crimen querer estudiar
pero si estudiar y amar el aprendizaje
es un crimen desconozco el sentido de
vivir
yo pasé esclava de un sistema que no me
hacía feliz el sistema educativo con el
que fui enseñada en lo que en ese
entonces denominada la gran cárcel de
cerebros
nicolette
odiaba ir a clases porque me sentía
atada en un tumulto de tareas y era más
grande que yo misma la excesiva carga
académica mataba poco a poco mis grandes
anhelos de dedicar tiempo al arte a la
lectura a ejercer el liderazgo social
por el que desde niña me inquieta yo me
preguntaba esto es cuestión de
supervivencia o de desarrollo de
competencias esto es cuestión de saberlo
todo o de saber lo suficiente para
encontrar una vocación esto es cuestión
de limitar o de dirigir la mente humana
hacia un éxtasis del que nunca se quiera
olvidar el aprendizaje
nuestra mente tiene una obstinada deseo
por tener todo bajo control por saberlo
todo saben cuál es la gran obsesión de
mi cerebro la información la información
lo vuelve loco lo emociona decodificar
la verificar la almacenarla y es que así
éramos de niños así somos pero al pasar
el tiempo empezamos en el colegio más
por sobrevivir por pasar la nota por
pasar el año porque toca y perdemos ese
entusiasmo
en esos momentos es cuando yo vi
frustrado mi sueño mi anhelo de crear un
mundo distinto y fue cuando ocurrió el
choque de dos mundos
mi mundo el que yo imaginaba
contra el mundo real
porque mientras yo imaginaba un lugar en
el que el aprendizaje se pudiera
disfrutar al máximo y el amor por el
conocimiento fuera la mayor motivación
para ir a estudiar un lugar en el que en
medio de curiosidad y libertad
todos se interesaran por leer escribir
aprender no por obligación sino por
gusto mientras yo hacía esto otra gran
parte de la humanidad que me rodeaba ya
estaba acostumbrada a no vivir en un
mundo así yo era las adaptadas que
pretendía cambiar todo el funcionamiento
de una institución que le había costado
años funcionar de ese modo
por eso decidí crear este espacio este
universo de emociones y el saber es por
mi propia cuenta a los 15 años
creo juventudes literarias y llegan a mi
vida las famosas chispitas nuestra magia
jota l'eliana
mi primer café literario fue un fracaso
con orgullo
recuerdo tanto que me convertí en el
spam alias la niña del café porque
invadía a los medios posibles para
invitar personas a la actividad no
obstante ese día sólo asistieron dos
jóvenes y lo más interesante es que como
yo fracaso con orgullo el mismo día
llegué a mi casa hice una publicación en
mi blog personal
que decía como ustedes pueden ver ahí
exitoso café literario y si tenemos la
palabra exitoso habían existido dos
personas pero para mí había sido un
éxito
eso es fracasar con orgullo
y ustedes creen que al pasar el tiempo
asistieron más personas
había ocasiones en las que llegaba al
suelo un joven
pero gracias a la maravillosa costumbre
que tenían mis papás de dejarme
esperando por horas cuando las clases
acababan me hice amiga de las calles y
la biblioteca pública se convirtió en mi
segundo hogar como dice un compañero la
literatura le dio alas a new beetle y
así fue me liberé saqué mi lado salvaje
mi lado instintivo a través del arte
pude expresar ese odio que llevaba
guardado en mi corazón y convertirlo en
un acto de servicio y amor
debe quejarme tanto el colegio y empecé
a darme a los demás
mi sentimiento de odio e inconformidad
se vio mediado por los libros
sin embargo todo eso hizo que mi crimen
aumentar cada vez me volvía más
insoportable mi mamá estaba preocupada
porque ella acostumbraba a recibir
medallas diplomas felicitaciones y ahora
recibía citaciones y malas
calificaciones porque inclusive yo me
haya tomado la locura de recoger mil
firmas para quitar las tareas en épocas
de bimestrales
saben algo yo me sentía como una
criminal pero empecé a darme cuenta que
mi sueño por querer mejorar el sistema
educativo no era un crimen sentirme
inexperta y no contar con todas las
herramientas para hacerlo no era un
crimen
ser joven no es un crimen intentar vivir
a los grandes siendo tan joven no era un
crimen en realidad es lo que hacemos
muchos pequeños en edad vivir a lo
grande
todos necesitamos un empujón en la vida
el mío sucedió durante una premiación de
talentos
cada año mi colegio exalta al mejor
rendimiento académico al mejor en
matemáticas al mejor en inglés y ustedes
creen que yo esperaba recibir algo no
pero mi profesora de filosofía quería
reconocer la labor que estaba haciendo y
se inventó un talento
un talento que yo no había escuchado
antes ese fue uno de los días más lindos
de mi estadía en la cárcel cuando la
escucha a ella decir desde la tarima
medalla de honor para angie michelle
moreno coronel por su talento en
pensamiento filosófico
y
pensamiento filosófico repetía en mi
mente qué es eso
cómo se come yo lo tengo me sentía
frustrada no sabía que era lo que me
estaban reconociendo este es el día y
tampoco lo entiendo pero derecho como
enviarlo ese día yo ya había empezado a
ir de la peor manera posible al colegio
se me había roto la correa en los
zapatos a mí no me habían portado así
pase al frente a recibir una de las
medallas más lindas que han entregado en
toda la vida esto este reconocimiento me
demostró que por ahí era el camino sin
embargo cuando tú tienes un sueño tu
sueño está expuesto a una constante
metamorfosis ilustró
en un principio empiezas inquietas luego
experimentas con ignorancia fracasas con
orgullo sigues trabajando
incansablemente
pasan cosas tu idea tuya se va aclarando
aparentemente llega el momento del
triunfo tumbas y
cómo
vuelves a empezar así son los sueños con
el tiempo mutan y ahí es cuando tú te
ves obligado a
cambia mejorar crecer
en momentos de amor fosis yo me suelo
preguntar
andy beach cuál es la razón social es
decir el verdadero valor
de tus aspiraciones
en un principio cuando empecé con toda
esta locura de querer cambiar el sistema
lo más difícil para mí fue creer que lo
que estaba haciendo realmente ayudaba a
alguien porque es muy triste cuando tú
das todo de ti y nadie recibe por ello
así que un día decidí alejarme de los
chicos y empecé a mirar todo en
perspectiva y al escuchar desde lejos
las risas de los muchachos comprendí que
a pesar de que lo que yo estuviera
haciendo no fuera lo más excelente del
mundo era valioso por una razón los
hacía felices a ellos verlos sonreír
me recuerda mi propósito su risa me
enseñó a fracasar con orgullo además
debo reconocer que me llena de mucha
ilusión imaginar el día en que aparezca
en las noticias colombia ha aumentado el
índice de lectura colombia es uno de los
países que más lee en el mundo guau
mi corazón se ensancha se hace un poco
más grande y espacioso cuando pienso en
esto siempre siempre he creído en el
poder de la unión del trabajo en equipo
del voluntariado porque saben
precisamente en el voluntariado donde yo
encontré mi gran motivación y mi gran
fortaleza para hacer este sueño en
realidad porque ser voluntario significa
sacar un pedazo de ti y entregárselo a
la comunidad decirles esto que era mío
ahora es de ustedes del corazón de
cientos de jota liriano así nos hacemos
llamar
tienen un sueño que tenemos un sueño
liberar los colombianos encadenados en
las famosas cárceles de cerebros cole
conocidas comúnmente como colegios
universidades y dirigidas por el actual
verdugo de la humanidad el sistema
educativo
intenso no así somos los jóvenes
apasionados
actualmente en juventudes literarias nos
dedicamos a crear experiencias de
aprendizaje
espero que se haya escuchado
emocionantes lo hacemos a través del
entretenimiento literario y educativo
tenemos el casino literario el dulce el
atari o el bosque literario el chocolat
ario la pizza literaria entre otras
metodologías de estudio reflexivo
expresión artística o servicio
comunitario en donde promovemos el
pensamiento ccs pensamiento creativo
crítico y social un concepto que
desarrolle en la fraternidad de la
fundación
al pasar el tiempo hemos crecido
bastante logramos llevar esta
experiencia que nació en cúcuta norte de
santander a otras partes del país y
hemos obtenido algunos reconocimientos
triunfos pero de todo ello yo quiero
resaltar una experiencia cuando el año
pasado en la presidencia de la
república- me entregó el premio nacional
de voluntariado juvenil recuerdo que al
terminar la ceremonia el presidente me
dijo las letras las letras son muy
importantes yo aproveché para decirle
señor presidente aporten a la educación
del país él me respondió por favor usted
desde sus jóvenes siga construyendo una
educación de calidad
este mensaje me tocó el corazón
porque significa que está en nosotros
los jóvenes y aquí directamente desde
norte de santander el hacerlo de hecho
precisamente ayer me enteré que este año
volvimos a ganar el premio y esta vez no
lo gané yo lo ganó otro cucuteño de la
fundación y esto me alegra mucho porque
es ver brillar nuestro departamento
todo todo este tiempo todas estas
vivencias me ayudaron a darme cuenta que
este compromiso es hasta la muerte que
yo me digo a mí misma no me puedo morir
sin al menos aportarle una uña a la
construcción de una verdadera de
educación de calidad para mi país además
me ayudó a concluir a que me quiero
dedicar el resto de mi vida
diseccionar cerebros humanos
literal y metafóricamente porque ahora
sé que quiero ser una neurosis o
pedagoga y aunque todavía no entré a la
universidad no me canso de prepararme
para esta meta colombia mejor educada
porque para mí estudiar nunca fue una
obligación era mi más ardiente deseo
hacerlo y eso hago ahora que salí de la
cárcel
además
cuando diriges una fundación siendo tan
joven
no es trabajo no tienes estudio
profesional
tu familia tiene bajos recursos
económicos
tienes dos hermanitos pequeños vives un
año en el que tu salud se ha visto
debilitada
[Aplausos]
está ahí
cuando te das cuenta que la vida es
difícil
pero que vivirla
vivirla por ti y para los demás vale
tanto
vale cada lágrima y lección
e
yo soy
una fábula andante me encanta
encontrarle moraleja a todo y si no la
tiene el invento el invento así que toda
esta experiencia he concluido que
hay que seguir siéndolo y hacerlo con
pasión y amor promover el amor por el
conocimiento vivir la educación desde el
entusiasmo desde el interés social y
voluntario de quien aprende
por alcanzar por un trabajo que es mucho
más valioso que el dinero
y es lograr la transformación social
basada en lo humano de nuestro ser y en
los académicos que podemos llegar a ser
después de todo este tiempo he podido
concluir que mi historia de vida se
podría resumir en una frase
del odio surge el amor
gracias a mi colegio descubrí este gran
amor que siento por lo que hago porque
de odiar mi institución educativa me
convertí en una defensora de la
educación es simple que aman
qué es lo que les duele a mí me duele la
educación de mi país
a mi menor me enojaba el sistema porque
porque yo amaba estudiar y cuando
alguien ama lo que hace lo hace genial y
muchas personas haciendo cosas geniales
son las que cambian el mundo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]